six reasons why
young adults need to get vaccinated i
think that's what it says six reasons
why young healthy people need to get
vaccinated go to the next one
long-term consequence of covid can be
quite serious for young adults can you
flip the screen to go on that instead of
ours
go ahead tom you see the guy josh
skidmore
the first comment six reasons why cnn
came back
i'm looking at the woman who gave birth
to nine babies two more than expected on
the bottom yeah i saw that as well so
long-term consequences of covid can be
called you got to hear point number six
by the way
long-term consequence of covad can be
quite serious for young adults i cannot
tell
you how many people have taken care of
in the er who in their 20s 30s and 40s
who are never
sick enough to end up in the er with
covet but who now have long-lasting
respiratory difficulties okay
fine so long-term keep going to the next
one uh strong and healthy immune systems
can backfire some young healthy patients
have suffered from covet
uh storms that's basically when an
immune system overreacts which can cause
severe inflammation other serious
symptoms when young people do succumb to
cover 19
pronounce that word for me cytokine
storms are
often a factor said dr paul offit that
was really the story of the 1918
pandemic the flu pandemic we have
u-shaped curve
it was a young and old dying for
different reasons okay go to the next
one this is next
third reason if young people don't get
vaccinated it could leave
everyone vulnerable we get that go to
the next one getting vaccinated will
help the economy many restaurants bars
movie theaters and supporting venues
aren't open at full capacity either
because the covenant case numbers are
still too high or because not enough
people have been
vaccinated go to the next one so they're
there so the reason why restaurants are
not opening up is because of the people
not because the u.s government that's
what they're saying vaccines can save
people lots of money
copenhagen could get very expensive
medical bills lost work days and
potential for more doctors visits if you
get a long-term effects from covered
okay keep going to the next one
getting vaccinated can up your dating
game this is the one okay
for those on dating scene getting
vaccinated or being open to getting it
is the hottest thing you could do said
michael spokesperson for dating site
okay cupid he said users who answered
yes
to will you get the kovic 19 vaccine
have been liked up to
25 more than those who answered no
or chose not to answer in just three
months tinder had a 258
increase in profile mentions of the word
vaccine
spokesperson dana bulge said so
i don't know i saw big media coverage of
crowds in daytona beach crowds in miami
crowds and south padre island it doesn't
look like the youth were waiting for uh
vaccines
i've taken two trips to new york in the
last few months
and people are really they're like yeah
i got over the hump today
i've you know and they're like brand new
excited they're like wow i'm out i'm out
i'm out i'm having a blast
i know some millennials who are like the
same way i
my co the co-founder of my company we're
sitting at lunch and he's like this is
my first lunch out danielle and i'm like
excuse me he's like yeah i waited two
weeks after i got my second vaccine and
i'm like congratulations
but there are some people who take it
pretty seriously it is true so so here's
a crazy thing what happened with bora
bora we're supposed to be bora bora in
four weeks
we get a letter from bora bora oh here's
what did you hear about bora bora
letter from bora bora saying there's
only two way you can come we're taking
like 150 people
there's only two way you can come you
can come only
if 100 of people are vaccinated or if
whoever comes is willing to
quarantine two weeks after being here to
go back to the state
even walking off the plane with a
negative test two weeks quartet so
maldives is open
turks and caicos is open but if you want
to go to bora bora today
you need to take a vaccine shot for them
to let you in
you need to show the guy you're not not
our group
so we are looking at a couple other
options right now where to go we're
supposed to be there four or five weeks
so now we're going
to take a couple other options i i i've
taken my hat off to the bahamians
yeah bora bora managed they're doing a
really really good job
they're doing a really good job i mean
and you saw what happened with australia
prime minister saying anybody that wants
to come here from india if you travel to
india you cannot come back where else
it's a fifty thousand dollar fine and
what is it how long in jail fifty fifty
one thousand dollar fine and you'll be
in jail for a
month two months maximum penalties five
years in jail and a fifty thousand
dollar fine if you come back if you're
an
australian citizen you fly back from
india to australia it's a fifty one
thousand dollar fine and five years in
jail
that's what the australian prime
minister said scott morrison
okay so if you ever go to india make
sure you don't go to australia because
they're going to put you in jail for
five years so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast
click over here take care everybody bye